I ate the key good for you now prepare
to be sliced open perfectly normal okay
what are you remembering how to turn
your head incorrectly no mannequins an
old rusty key or a rusty old key
sorry I'm Dyslexic that candy exploded
why must have been some candy carefully
detailed illustration of a human arm
being dipped in bronze with oh that's
why he oranges and we're just brownies a
guide dipped in bronze where did that
come from
where'd it go the shadow was there and
now oh hey Medusa winner winner chicken
dinner these transmissions have given us
the blueprints to technology far more
advanced than anything we've ever seen
what is that is that a goo goo goo goo
goo ghost use a pranchi tapara solve our
us way progress oh gosh nike's where am
I now
see bones are sweet Oh get out okay
ghosty goo are you out here
false book a false book okay so I gotta
put him in an order wow I'm a genius
seeing them die was an epiphany there is
beauty and death I've never forgotten
William Kraven is a crazy son of a [ __ ]
hey I was talking about you being ugly
and all that I meant that you were so
beautiful I love that soup
I see where this is going oh maybe not
all right there yes oh my god run man
run run run you stupid douche ah
I'm the Wiener this has been the random
horror reaction compilation thanks for
watching
if you liked what you saw and you want
to see more why not subscribe to my
channel want to help the channel grow
please leave a like add it to your
favorites or share it with your friends
on Facebook and Twitter thanks again and
as always I will see you in the next
video
yeah